Good morning Hank, it's Tuesday.
So, the American Library Association's Office for Intellectual Freedom just released it's list
of the ten most challenged books of the year in the United States.
'Challenged' meaning someone requested to have the book removed from the school or library
And it turns out that the most challenged book of 2015 was "Looking For Alaska"
which was written by me
The book has been challenged and banned around the country for 'offensive language' and 'sexually explicit' descriptions
I suppose this is a kind of honor, I mean Looking For Alaska contained the very same offensive language
and sexually explicit descriptions as it did ten years ago, but was much less likely to be banned
because, you know, not many people had read it.
Also, Looking For Alaska beat some of my favorite books, like 'Two Boys Kissing' by David Levithan
and 'Fun House' by Alison Bechdel
and also the Holy Bible, which came in 6th.
To be fair, the Bible does contain it's fair share of explicit passages
Anyway, I'm often asked to respond to the banning of Looking For Alaska from schools and libraries, so okay.
Here is my response:
Text is meaningless without context, and what usually happens with Looking For Alaska is
that a parent chose one particular page of the novel to an administrator and then the book gets banned
without anyone, who objects to it, having read more then that one particular page.
The scene in question involves a very awkward and ultimately failed attempt at oral sex
which is described in very cold and clinical language, in fact the entire passage contains only one adjective: nervous
And then in the book's next scene, two characters have a much more sensually described and passionate
but much less sexually explicit interaction.
That passage ends: "We didn't have sex, we never got naked, I never touched her bare breasts,
and her hands never got lower than my hips. It didn't matter. As she slept, I whispered: "I love you, Alaska Young"
So in context, the novel is arguing, really in a rather pointed way,
that emotionally intimate kissing can be a whole lot more fulfilling than emotionally empty oral sex.
Teenagers are critically engaged and thoughtful readers
They do not read Looking For Alaska and think: "I should go have some agressively unerotic oral sex."
And they also don't read 'The Outsiders' and think: "I should join a gang."
Or read 'Divergent' and think: "I should jump onto moving trains."
So as far as I can tell, that kind of narrow perscriptive reading seems only to happen inside
the offices of school superintendents.
So yeah, I don't think Looking For Alaska is pornographic, and I don't think it's readers find it titillating.
But that noted, I don't think it should be up to me whether Looking For Alaska, or actually any book
is in a school or a library. Because I am not a teacher or a librarian.
The highly trained, criminally underpaid professionals we'd employed to make those decisions.
As I've discussed in the past, I don't think publicly  funded learning exists primarily for the benefit of parents
or even primarily for the benefit of students.
It exists for the benefit of the social order.
We are all better of with a well-informed, well-educated population
because that population is more likely to start successful businesses and develop treatments for cancer.
And write musicals about treasury secretaries.
And that's why everyone pays taxes, to fund public schools and libraries,
regardless of whether you personally use the library or have kids in school
I think teachers and librarians know more about teaching and librarianship than I do.
And I believe they must be allowed to do their jobs, serving the whole public.
But even beyond that, I don't believe that books, even bad books, corrupt us.
Instead I believe books challenge and interrogate, they give us windows into the lives of others
and give us mirrors so that we can better see ourselves.
And ultimately, if you have a worldview that can be undone by a novel
Let me submit that the problem is not with the novel...
Hank, I'll see you on Friday